[Music]
okay years ago i went on a vacation with
my girlfriend at the time and we each
decided to bring uh friends of ours i
brought christian and my friend james
and she brought a bunch of friends a
bunch of friends yeah it was a little
island in the bahamas it was beautiful
but it was also a little bit
rustic would you say like there weren't
many amenities it was diy it was a diy
bahamanian vacation and my girlfriend
and her friends were not into it at all
so we decided to cut the trip short it
was which was really heartbreaking for
me that night we flew to miami and we
ate at nobu which is this very fancy
sushi restaurant and almost on cue
one by one the kardashians walk in
and it's one of those moments in life
where you just look at your friends and
you don't have to say anything you just
share this like silent understanding and
i was furious because my favorite
kardashian courtney
wasn't there oh yeah i was beside myself
yeah it was really i thought i was mad
about leaving that island but then
courtney wasn't there and my night was
ruined you kept looking around tell me
she's coming
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always uh is my brother
christian who was also with me on that
fateful day in the bahamas and then
fateful day it was like the ice of march
i guess
it had some faith it was a day it wasn't
full of it was a day that i remember
very clearly i know i do too and i
remember remember how good those those
lobster we caught i mean i don't want to
dwell on this but it was so fun catching
our own lobsters the day before well i
couldn't catch them because i know about
sensitive ears and if i go below a
certain depth in the water my ears start
hurting oh yeah and my girlfriend who
was great i should say and if she's
listening was was swimming around like a
fish she was able to go she was amazing
amazing she caught like 30 lobsters i
know and
uh and we were i mean the animal rights
people aren't going to like this but we
were it was spear fishing so we were
like yeah it was really cool but we
spiny lobsters they weren't like the um
atlantic uh lobsters with the claws they
had so we ate that night we grilled them
on the beach remember how good
oh god how tender those things were and
all her friends were like miserably
eating this delicious lobster and
they're like ah what's for dessert yeah
they didn't catch any of them we caught
all these lobsters for them and they
cooked them cleaned them yeah did all
the dishes is there are there any
toppings yeah okay well anyway they were
uh they just like different things they
wanted a different thing but the irony
to me was the next day when we went to
miami when we went to novu where we saw
christian's favorite kourtney kardashian
didn't see her i'm sorry to bring that
up again um
we they ordered the lobster and they
were going on about how good they were
oh my god
i forgot about that it was so ironic it
was like this like you know
70 80 lobster dish and the night before
we had this like oh anyway and nothing
against miami it's it's a fun place and
it's yeah i know but it's it's just when
you're when your body and mind are
accustomed to living in the swiss family
robinson type existence for four days
and then all of a sudden within like the
blink of an eye you're next to the
kardashians miami there's like pit bull
music everywhere
it it's the most jarring thing i felt
like a fish that was like yanked out of
the water and i was like where am i and
it's like flopping around in land can
you imagine how actual
people who are native to islands like
that um
must feel when they go
to a city like a pod a civil like a
populated uh
pretty wild first world
you know i'm really
obsessed with the sentinel islands do
you know anything about the sentinel
uh they're still like the oldest natives
yeah and they've been untouched to the
point where whenever the few times
planes have flown over they throw spears
and stuff and they
um they're just they have no
no access to like the outside why would
the planes have to throw spears no no no
they throw spears at the plants oh oh my
god duh
i was like that seems really
old-fashioned
this is a long time ago
so the wright brothers flew over
um
anyway why are we talking about uh this
why are we talking about well
specifically we're talking about the
kardashians even more specifically kim
kardashian i think is because our guest
today had a quite public
feud
i would say with kim kardashian did you
almost say cat fight no oh i i i wasn't
that wasn't my first time i find that
term offensive yeah i know you do but
it is it i can see why it is offensive i
it was the first time i was going to say
that
publicly i wasn't even going to say it i
just i almost i almost said something
else
i almost said beef but then i thought
that was a gross word they had very
public beef but they had a public feud
whatever word you want to use um so our
guest is jamila jamil
jamila jamil is such a
impressive
she's so smart and are articulate
beautiful uh very funny
um so to use it makes it even worse to
use the word beef to associate enough
with her she's an actress on the good
place but i would say she's much more
well known for being an activist yeah
that's how i discovered her me too i my
another girlfriend
uh was a big fan of hers and would
was following her on twitter and uh so i
started
becoming aware of her twit i know it
sounds lame but like i discovered her
through twitter i started seeing her
tweets and stuff and like
i was like who is saying like really
speaking a true activist like speaking
truth to power which is a
very scary rare thing we talk a lot
about that um i'm fascinated by
someone's ability to do that and jamila
has used her platform for so much good
it's created a lot of con she's created
a lot of controversies well like a
lightning rod in the case i mean she
goes after these
really really famous people like kim
kardashian like cardi b so she went
after her
oh sorry cardiff i always get that wrong
what do you say that when you separate
sorry i i think i saw them separated
once and now my brain can't reconnect
um cody berenson she went after
cardis embarrassing
uh she went after kim kardashian i i
think for um kim kardashian was
promoting these these diet pills or
something for you know that teenagers
were young girls were pretty crazy
buying them and uh so jamila's one of
her huge movements one of her the things
she knows she's known for is this i way
movement which is about empowering young
girls specifically but um generally it's
about uh
you know i guess it is generally about
empowering women but specifically it's
about um
like body issues and how to be okay with
your body and how to accept uh certain
truths and limitations but and just
reconstructuring the um body norms and
and just the societal pressure that that
reconstructing what did i say
reconstructuring oh weird okay she's
also a lightning rod i would say so she
angers a lot of people and
you guys talk about this but uh a lot of
people
are get upset with her and and uh
so and i know we try to stay away from
politics on the show so my interest in
her is not political as much as it is
personal and how she deals with just
regardless of where i stand on the
political spectrum i think she's an
interesting figure and uh and i'm and
i'm curious how i was curious how she
deals with um being such a polarizing
figure in the world in this world that's
so polarizing and i think another uh
admirable thing worth mentioning is that
is her ability to
engage in discourse social media creates
a very difficult environment to do that
i mean it's it's very that's why there
are these echo chambers and and you know
we talked we've talked a lot about that
on the show and
um it only promotes tribalism but but
shamila is uh very open to discourse and
having a dialogue
and she is against any kind of rigid
structures uh strictures i should say on
conversations that need to be happening
so i think in that sense she's
an asset to the times we live in um and
and the need for uh more nuance in
having some of these debates well said
thank you let's uh let's get to it this
is my conversation with the very
impressive whipsmart resplendent jamila
jamel
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
i'll wait till on the podcast to tell
you a bone i have to pick with you about
one of your film roles that [ __ ] me up
for life oh i can't wait to hear about a
bone yeah what's the bone okay so should
we just get it yeah jeep as [ __ ]
creepers okay that film has [ __ ] me up
for my whole life i have never been okay
since i saw that film even though the
cgi isn't always amazing no i'm not
gonna lie it was 2001 so you know let's
remember the time um but it was
incredibly effective and now i still
think that that demon is outside my
window every single day
i don't look outside of my window at
night because i think it's going to be
there and i'm 33 i saw that film 18
years ago i was going to ask you yeah
how old you were when you started a
teenager
[Music]
that's the film that made me realize i
can't watch horror movies anymore oh
really yeah because it just permeated my
soul uh in a way that made me realize
that i'm too much of a [ __ ] to
withstand these things even no matter
how fantastical and ridiculous they are
yeah i i am petrified
and i blame you oh okay so well i'll
take that coming to fight it's weirdly
uh complimentary when you hear something
that it was effective like that but see
i for me
for me personally uh for me the first
half is really effective it's the stuff
that you don't see yes you know um
and then once you see that it's like
okay it's a it's me you can kind of
see that it's a movie you know yeah yeah
yeah i remember there was a line in that
that got cut that um fortunately he the
director cut um that the creeper set
spoke at one point oh no yeah and the
guy had like a weird southern accent he
was like he smelled the old lady eileen
brennan who's
so good um he smells her and and she
goes uh she don't smell too good darius
it was really weird yeah
yeah he was trying to sound menacing you
know it's like you don't have to do
anything no
it and also like seeing it
up close you know when it when when you
finally see its face and it looks a bit
like a genital wart
like
yeah
it was at one point called the untitled
channel war project wonderful yeah
wonderful it was a general award that
came
alive every 23rd spring this guy gets a
flare up yeah and that's what it feels
like it's waiting for me outside of my
window every single night
well done yeah thanks
what do people say what is their
response to you when they see you when
they they spy what bones do they have to
pick with you
i mean i think some people just think
i'm a bit much which is not fair
i am i think just the fact that i'm
always banging on about something
very outspoken so and so frequently
outspoken and i think that that
especially when you see a woman doing it
we're so unaccustomed to seeing that yes
so it's particularly grating um and
uh especially a woman who looks like you
a woman of a different color yes exactly
no no you can say it you do have a
different color so i do have a different
color a neon um
i um yeah
i uh and so you know i think people are
unaccustomed to that it's grating and
also
you know i understand how it must feel
like oh jesus she never takes a day off
but unfortunately nor do the things that
i'm fighting so the way that i am kind
of balancing this out is that when shame
takes a day off so will i yes but until
we until we stop hurting people why
should i stop defending them uh and so
like i don't really give a [ __ ] like i
don't care if you like me or not i'd
like you personally to like me yeah i do
like you um so far yeah
we have an hour i'd like you to just
kind of shut up though yeah i know um
no i'm kidding i i can't wait to talk to
you about these things
it's a liberating thing of like you know
i play this character on the good place
where her uh the thing that has most
held her back in life is her obsession
with wanting to be liked and wanting to
be approved of and having people admire
her yeah and uh that was a great
learning curve for me because it was
around the time of understanding her
obsession that helped me distance myself
from mine because i think women in
particular are conditioned that we have
to be likable and we have to be liked
and we have to be easy to be around
implicating and seeing how much that
held her back in life made me register
that in myself oh interesting characters
yeah and so that was a great turning
point in the fact that i was just
turning 30 when i started as tahani and
i stepped into my power of not feeling
like i needed to be liked by anyone
other than my boyfriend yeah that would
be important which is great if you
didn't like it well if it frees you up
in activism because sometimes people can
be held back by the fragility of their
ego i could not understand that more
which is i think why i so admire you
um i i discovered you before i
discovered you as an actress i
discovered you uh as an outspoken
activist and and um
i did i had no idea what your background
was i just knew that the things you were
saying were very
uh compelling and and powerful and and
incendiary uh and so i i wondered and i
continue to wonder how
you do that how you're able to set your
ego aside and and like you said not care
what people think i i struggle with that
so i it's it's something that i
really deeply admire uh how how do you
do that it can't be all through this
character no it wasn't all through the
character i also had a therapy called
emdr eye movement desensitization and
reprocessing therapy
and so that just involves sitting and
looking at a wall where there is a light
moving across that wall back and forth
and you think of your greatest so the
way to break it down i'm terrible at
breaking this down i'm not going to go
into this in any great detail because uh
i am not an expert but all i can tell
you is that it's a therapy that has been
around for a long time that is coming
into the mainstream now that was
designed for ptsd there are very few
therapies that are effective with trauma
and what this does is it basically is a
very very simple way of reorganizing
thoughts from the irrational to the
rational part of your brain because
trauma can trauma can can leave you with
irrational fears oh sure i need the emdr
jeep as creepers
realized just now so i can stop waiting
for that std yeah
yeah right outside your windows inside
of my bedroom window yeah um but
you know there's a direct correlation
between eye movement and thought process
as you look you know the way that our
eyes move when we're sleeping oh yeah i
think it's called rem yes i'm not mad
i'm not just talking about the band that
is a thing no it's not good
yeah uh no and there are certain tells
right too when you're when you're lying
if you look to it left i think that's
where the creative side of your brain is
and if you recall a memory we often look
up for some reason and so
because of that correlation they
designed a type of therapy that uses
your eye movement to move thoughts
around and reorganize your brain
essentially incredible and when you're
doing it it feels so
boring and nonsensical and you feel like
a dog and you feel offended and that
your intelligence is being undermined
yeah and you feel a little bit like uh
someone is reducing your problems down
to this like your incredibly traumatic
problems down to this very simple
technique yes
it does almost feel like your experience
is being undermined and yet it is so
effective it works so quickly i use that
to get rid of a lot of my traumas which
help me separate my
pride from what is actually important
we often especially actors or people in
show business have like an irrational
almost psychosis around uh other
people's opinion of us yes some people
say that we get into show business
because we didn't feel i'm not saying
that for everyone but we want to be
liked and because we weren't liked maybe
by someone very important in our lives
we need we need to be loved and liked by
the rest of the world i can't relate to
that no
no
i wonder if it shines a light on the
fact that we're all just these
machines we're not quite as complex as
uh we sometimes think we're all the
product of our environments and you know
a lot of us carry trauma and we think of
trauma only as having survived a war or
you know being attacked by lots of
people all at once um but trauma can
happen in really insidious ways and i've
i've experienced trauma in so many
different ways i had like an abusive
childhood and then i was physically
bullied really badly at school as well
and i was deaf until i was 12 and
bullied for being deaf that's it yeah
and then i'm just a woman and then i'm a
pakistani woman growing up in the most
racist time in england towards my people
and so i was just saddled with so much
trauma that i didn't even know what to
do with it and i become a product just
of that and my basic personality was
made up of like a million different
types of ptsd and psychosis just wrapped
up into one busty bundle
one lovable yeah and how does that end
where how does that live where does that
live how does it manifest itself that
must be such a what a journey that must
have been yeah well i i had anxiety and
depression and i was suicidal probably
until i was about 27 or 28. you speak
about this you're very open about this
and
that's something that that alone is uh
very noble i think but it's
it's also a surprise i mean
i mean it's like purely superficially
and i know you get a lot of i read a lot
of the comments that people write to you
and a lot of them are a version of
what do you have to be
depressed about i mean you know it's a
very like and we live in that culture
and i'm a product of that culture look
at you i can't
just in researching you i i was stunned
to find out that you had withstood all
of these
tragic events in your life but what's so
amazing about it is how uh common it is
like you know the life that i've lived
sounds extraordinary because we haven't
heard many people just come out and say
it because we stigmatize people
talking about their trauma and we
stigmatize the concept of the victim um
and we don't open up about our feelings
enough which is why i rally so hard to
destigmatize these things and just talk
about everything very openly um
but the most amazing thing
about my
very sad and and like broken life is the
fact that it is so common so many people
share all of these experiences with me
and that has been the thing that i found
the most profound about speaking out
about them is that the majority of the
feedback i get is other people having
shared or worse experiences yes and you
said something recently you you
addressed that to some degree when you
you had it it wasn't a bill passed but
it was a a measure passed uh
on instagram that was preventing uh
certain companies from targeting
uh yeah so we managed to get instagram
or facebook i got a petition i got 250
000 signatures in three days it's
amazing what's the result of being a bit
much uh right well but effective and
yeah and somebody wrote to you they said
you know thank you for doing this they
gave you all of the credit and you said
something really
i i think important and selfless which
was
i only i did this i have the power to do
this but it's not as though i did this
on my own no and this i mean there's so
many activists who've come before me but
also the community of predominantly
women but lots of different people
behind me who helped me get all these
laws passed we basically changed the
global policy among across instagram and
facebook worldwide to um stop miners
from being able to consume like being
able to buy or be exposed to diet detox
products or cosmetic surgery what was
behind that what was the motivation that
what compelled you to do that i was just
your own struggle yeah i was like i've
said i've need to start when i was young
anyone who was famous recommended
anything that they attributed their very
thin physique to i would buy gwyneth
paltrow said in a mainstream magazine
back then and she was young and didn't
know any better um but she said that i
eat in front of a mirror naked to stop
myself from over indulging which is
obviously very antisocial in restaurants
not to be advised
well first of all you need a mirror in
the rest yeah i got into quite a lot of
trouble following that tip uh thanks
gwyneth
well it's huge and the fact that it
reached somebody like me somebody with
uh stop taking laxatives i no
unfortunately i just love the feeling
but um but that's a whole different
issue that's a different um podcast uh i
it's so important it's really admirable
but how did you speaking of the [ __ ]
fest that is hollywood yeah uh how what
how did you get into that [ __ ] fest what
you were you had been um a host and then
well yeah so i started as a teacher an
english teacher an english teacher which
i don't see i'm kidding
no you're
incredibly articulate so i that makes
sense why did you teach uh both english
literature but also to teach in a school
teaching english as a foreign language
uh which which meant that you would have
to teach people who didn't speak one
word of english and what was the other
language
they would speak i mean any other
language in the world so sometimes you'd
have 17 different nationalities in one
class and none of them speak the same
language as each other so you basically
have to just communicate with each other
in the first weeks via purely mime are
you like charlie chaplin seriously i
once remember having i had this class of
70 year old nuns who were from poland
and i had to explain to them
why via the art only of mime they
shouldn't pronounce sitting as [ __ ]
which was one of the more traumatic
and i had to squat
and then
use my fist
as a representative of [ __ ] and then
make it drop to the ground
and then watch these mortified 70 year
old nuns look at me i'm going straight
to hell just for that never mind
everything yeah straight
uh for everything i've done i would pay
i'm trying to think of how much money i
would pay to for a video of that session
but i'll do it after this well i mostly
want to see their reaction i think
that's how i get the most we can get
some we can get some nuns um
but uh yeah that was that was a
hilarious job but it sort of set me up
for hosting because i think when you can
do that you can do anything you can
communicate to if you can communicate to
several polish nuns i had no desire to
ever be in show business i didn't want
to be in front of a camera i have severe
like body dysmorphia like i have all of
the issues i mean you should never be
scrutinized in the public limelight and
yet unfortunately hollywood doesn't do
that no i know that's why i came here
i feel safe now
so
i uh was scouted in a pub by a man who i
got chatting to he thought i was funny
he told me that he thought i should go
for this big nationwide audition it was
an open call i said no and then he said
it was a thousand pounds a day and i was
like please give me the email
and i did a phone number
how much yeah exactly uh
i went for the job and got it and so i'd
never done any any kind of show business
stuff before and i found myself live on
television
on the biggest youth programming
show in the history of the uk
overnight
i was 22. wow i really had no idea what
i was doing and they gave me no they
gave me no [ __ ] instruction other
than literally when the red light goes
on above the camera don't say [ __ ]
that's it that was all the instruction i
was given and then told to read a
teleprompter and i was live on my own
and i'll never forget the fact that um
when i was on that
i was on this [ __ ] show live it's my
first ever like link out into the world
and i'm i'm reading the teleprompter
everything goes well i come to the end i
think i'm finished and i have an
earpiece in and someone says the network
haven't taken us phil
so i don't know what that means i'm 22.
right so what it means is which i now
know but i didn't know at the time it
means that we are still live on air i
think i finished but i'm still on the tv
with no lines left to say and that
there's been a problem in live where
sometimes the network isn't able to take
you to the adverts there's a problem so
they're just staying on you and they
can't get off
but i don't understand that that's what
that means because no one's told me [ __ ]
all so i so they keep going phil phil
phil again they haven't told me
beforehand that phil means come up with
any [ __ ] to say yeah to keep it
going so it doesn't look like there's a
mistake yeah and and they keep saying
phil phil phil phil so i think i'm
finished and i'm like i start saying out
loud i'm like hey um guys i think
they're looking for phil
uh oh he's like phil
phil are you phil um phil phil
and they're keeping like no phil and i
was like guys they really need phil uh
it's an emergency and so my first ever
live link on television is a minute of
me going and it ends on where the [ __ ]
is awesome i dropped the f stuff
in the end thank god social media wasn't
yet a thing when that went out because
it would have gone viral no i don't have
that i'm sure the network of it i'm sure
they'll bring it back to torture me with
at some point again another moment i'd
like to witness in your life i'd like to
see the people's reactions the non-fills
who are like
very embarrassing but anyway so i
somehow survived that day carried on to
broadcast eventually moved into radio
because i found television to i found my
career was becoming centered around the
way that i looked and what i wore
and i was being undermined as nothing
more than just my face my male writers
would tell me that i couldn't do
anything funny uh because i wasn't funny
and i was just here to look nice and i
was being told that explicitly no [ __ ]
yeah and so i wanted to move into radio
to prove that i had a brain and i was
you know someone beyond my aesthetic and
so i did that and that went well for a
couple of years and i got i became the
first woman to ever host the official
chart on radio one which is our kind of
billboard 100 it's been on air for 60
years and a woman's never hosted it
before that was a really cool moment for
me yeah i'll say this and you're in your
20s yeah i was 25 and then when that
happened i was also on steroids for
asthma and gaining a lot of weight and
the papers decided to not document this
history that i'd made but instead
document this document this weight that
i had gained yeah as if that was much
more important paparazzi photographed me
like pictures just of my arse and my
thighs
for about four months during my
during this incredible moment in my
career and what was amazing is that i
was on the [ __ ] radio you can't see
me what does it matter as long as i'm
not so fat that i can't open my mouth
like there is nothing there's no reason
that you should yes
no
all of the men on that network were very
curvaceous we all had the same size we
have the same cup size like all of us
like why is it an issue for me but not
for them because and that was the most
explicit moment of realizing wow
it doesn't matter what you achieve as a
woman as an intellectual as a
broadcaster as an activist nothing
matters other than being thin if you're
a woman it's really scary to think the
the impact that this is having on a
generation and yeah so again not to
labor the point but it is that much more
important the work that you're doing to
combat that because i think we need
we're desperate for voices like yeah
i refuse to let anyone photoshop me at
all even when i just shot the cover of
vogue and it was the first
unphotoshopped cover of vogue
no it was really cool and uh
peter lindbergh who's just died which is
sad but it was one of his final shoots
so it's amazing to get to work with him
and he hates photoshop anyway so it was
a real joy working together uh but i all
my magazine covers completely
unphotoshopped all my photographs that
go on the internet and also my billboard
now it's really hard to get a billboard
um what the [ __ ] is with the airbrushing
on billboards everyone looks insane yeah
well it's probably yeah it looks they
everyone looks [ __ ] they don't look like
real people it makes everyone look
creepy um but even
so it took me a while to fight nbc on
that but they were super cool i think as
they watched more and more of my
activism they realized that i'm so
[ __ ] annoying that it's just easier
just to do it to get me to like [ __ ] off
um and so
even in the group shot of the good place
everyone else is photoshopped but i'm
not i'm not like don't get that little
yeah everyone was like stay away from us
with your weird [ __ ] rules um and i
was i'm there with my little roll of
back fat that they kept on trying to
erase and i was like guys they kept
sending me email emails back just you
know just saying are you sure and i was
like yes i'm sure because that is my
back i've got a little bit of back fat
wow who doesn't have a little back tick
well i don't i mean i have a beautiful
pack i'm known for my bag um
i mean it's such a rare thing it's one
thing to do it publicly and to say that
you're doing this and and to do the
occasional oh i'm gonna little crumbs
you know but to to stick to it like that
is is incredible i mean
it costed me a lot of money because i
can't do any endorsements because i
can't get any brands to agree to not
photoshop me so i'm just like well i
can't i think i gave up three million in
endorsements this year oh my god
i didn't earn three million this year in
other ways
that was that was a house yeah several
houses um
but i i walk the walk to my own
detriment because i'm determined to
change the way that we treat people
we've had huge success cvs have stopped
uh airbrushing their photographs for
their beauty products and stuff so it's
it's becoming a thing and more and more
magazines are getting on board and i
just need more celebrities to [ __ ]
step up and actually do this and stop
like liking the pictures of my activism
and actually do it with me yeah like i
appreciate your words i appreciate your
dms i appreciate the things you say to
me in private events but i would love it
if you would also join me in on this put
your money where you're at yeah
otherwise like we're not progressing
like just retweeting me is an activism
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello
we'll meet again
[Music]
i love asking men how much they earn at
the same job as me oh yeah i bet that
was one of my favorite questions
do you do that on set do you think oh
really yeah i get weird did you do good
it just
shouldn't be weird yeah why has that
been made a weird question i know it's
so silly
well i guess people might be embarrassed
but just to play devil's advocate
people are embarrassed by saying how
much they make because it's probably a
lot yeah
but if we're at the same level
and we're doing the same job yeah then
why are you embarrassed to be telling me
how much you earn when it should be the
same it's different i don't expect to
earn the same amount as ted danson right
there's a seniority yeah he's like been
doing this a lot longer he's got more
experience he's also just better and
more charismatic than i will ever be but
anyone will ever be he's paid a charisma
bonus uh for sure and so i'll never get
that bonus yeah he decides to make all
the money in the world yeah he can have
it all he can have my paycheck
jeff goldblum should just be
billionaires but the rest of us we're on
like more of an even playing field so
like you know hey what's happening
what's uh what's coming into your wallet
do you see that changing at all do you
see that yeah i mean mike sure is really
cool and he pays like the boys and the
girls equally um when they're at the
same level and i really like that and
he's also got 50 50
uh
pretty much 50 50 writers room and
directors female to male so that was
really cool well that sounds like a good
place to work it was an amazing place to
work i'm sad that it's over yeah oh it's
over it's over it's done yeah how many
seasons four
yeah we just finished and so uh the
finale is going to air in the next
couple of months but the final season's
been airing and um
and it's well it's cool to be able to be
in control of the ending you know like
it was mike's decision rather than the
network the network would have i think
had us carry on for a long time
does well then yeah it does pretty well
um around the world but uh he just
didn't want to do it he wanted to be
very careful not to follow in the
footsteps of other high concept shows
that we've loved that went on too far
and disappeared off their own yeah well
that makes sense i mean yeah this might
be a controversial thing to say of all
the things we've said but seinfeld a
show that i was obsessed with i think
the last two seasons i think once larry
david left you really felt a difference
exactly and like you know even with
friends which is the show that i love so
much and they were my friends until i
was 19. yeah basically but uh you know
there were seasons of that show where
you're like god they're really like
flogging a dead horse yeah jumped the
shark yeah uh a while ago i don't know
if that's even an expression well i've
made it one now flagging a devil bad at
idioms yeah flagging a dead horse james
james
fly
beating it beating a dead horse
beating
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
isn't flagging a sexual thing right now
is that you thinking of flogging the
dolphin which is what he talks about in
something about mary when he's talking
about making sure that he comes before
his date
maybe flogging the dolphins yeah i don't
know about this
no you said james that was
oh he's so much more educated than me
we say beating a dead horse is the same
thing
you know what i one of my worst
malapropisms in england let's be honest
that's true one of my worst monopropisms
thank you i love you bye
[Laughter]
i thought it was
[Laughter]
james
for you and for the people at home james
james just
walked into a glass door and he's okay
are you okay
um one of my worst manipulations was
don't kick a gift horse in the mouth why
would you ever kick a horse in the mouth
and i said that by the way for 31 years
with complete confidence and because
i've been famous for nine of those years
no one [ __ ] corrected me so i've been
walking around like an [ __ ] talking
about horses yeah like a horse's [ __ ]
talking about kicking a gift horse in
the mouth it's look a gift horse in the
mouth which i didn't know
much more sense
i still can't get over that that was
james walking into that window it was
really
that was really funny when she'd seen
that
veneer of cool is broken forever no
that's a you know what's funny you can
tell a lot about somebody in a moment
like that
he didn't try to play it off like cool
like oh no
he sort of called attention to yeah he
appreciated my my favorite thing is when
people look angry at the thing they're
tripping yeah that's it's the best truly
one of the best human moments in the
world you know when someone trips over
something on the
sidewalk and then they turn around and
they stare at the sidewalk
um i love the blame i can't i'm so
clumsy uh that i've had so many
accidents i've had accidents live on air
like i've i once tripped over and fell
over and landed on my face and i lost my
front tooth broke my nose
got a concussion and broke my elbow all
on national television live yeah holy
[ __ ] i kept on airing it all day to make
sure that no one missed that moment
my skirt flew over my head and uh
my bum was revealed but they put a logo
for the channel over my bum so use my
bum as advertising space like a bum
board instead of
that's
a
funny what was the logo for their uh
studio yeah oh it'd be funny it was just
like a little like wacky face emoji yeah
just the poo emoji yeah the peach
uh holy [ __ ] which broke a tooth
oh my god so it must have been quite
violent it was really painful i was too
scared to get my nose fixed because i
was afraid of looking like michael
jackson
you better have a long way to go yeah i
know i was just worried um
ignorant of you i know um
wow well see now if it's a fall like
that i i i don't laugh no matter who it
is no i can't laugh at that that's just
too oh it's really funny at the time
jesus
pretty amazing and i used eyelash glue
to stick my teeth back in and i kept
filming with one arm like hanging lower
than the other were you bleeding you
must have been bleeding well no because
the tip the root was still attached so i
used your clothes my nose was bleeding
yeah but i cleaned it up oh my god what
type of show was that this was a hosting
show it was like a hosting show in
england we were doing up this community
center for this uh sort of marginalized
community and so it i knew that if i got
on that ambulance and went to the
hospital but then the show would be over
and then the school wouldn't get what
they needed so uh
but i was also very concussed and i
think made a bad decision
well you're very compassionate when
you're concussed yeah yeah i mean i
guess i guess that's that's that's good
but what a stupid [ __ ] decision
i could have died they maybe sign a wave
at it if i die it's not their fault
what is it then that
made you continue to want to be
out there and persist in turn to get to
where you are now in entertainment
uh
what was in how did you enjoy it did you
just enjoy doing it no
i'm not good
all right i just didn't really enjoy it
but i was really mentally ill for like
most of the time i've been in
in entertainment and so i enjoy it now
but when i was successful in my 20s i
just wanted to die
really so yeah and you know i was
playing the part of this like it girl is
that out djing these fancy parties being
photographer celebrities but i hated all
of them um and uh the people the parties
is that where the depression came or did
that no no depression came from having a
terrible childhood it just surfaces in
your twenties because like there's an
easter egg you can like push it down
before it starts to find its way up um
you know our generation of parents uh uh
think it's embarrassing to go to
therapists it's a sign of failed
parenthood on their part sure going back
to the i just the peter jackson
documentary about world war one about
the trench warfare and what the soldiers
went through when they came home it was
just
not talked about i mean they saw the
worst of humanity for like
years in some cases and
they just never talked about it so that
then i gets passed down i you you were
talking about trauma that gets passed
down that's uh certainly trauma that for
sure inherited yeah and my my lineage is
you know like pakistani people and
everything they went through and the
fact that pakistan exists you know it is
a
country being ripped in half you know
which is what happened in india and so
like there's so much pain in my lineage
and that i do believe that there's an
element of that that cannot help but be
passed down oh sure oh my god i have
friends whose parents were in the
holocaust and i think they still feel
effects of that i mean diluted certainly
but
where were your parents first
generations yeah wow and so that was
that came also with its own like
tremendous wave of racism like it was
bad in the 90s but i can't even imagine
what it was like in the 50s and 60s
which is when they came over so it's
just there's a lot there's a lot of pain
it's a lot of paranoia but the point is
is that i just persisted in show
business because it was very well paid
yeah you know and that makes being
insane easier oh my god because then you
can afford the things that make you a
bit happier for the moment you know and
you can pay rent and i can't imagine
what my life would have been like if i'd
been in this situation as most people in
this world who don't have access to
financial like
you know benefits whatever they don't
have money and then they're also
mentally ill and struggling and doing
these incredibly hard jobs for almost no
money and trying to make ends meet while
also
suffering um what saved you mentally i
mean what was it that
therapy i went to a therapist and told
her my life story and she was like oh my
god it would take me [ __ ] years i
needed to deal with you we'd have to go
to switzerland she said we're talking
seven to ten years and i just don't
think you can afford it
um and so she's sent me to this
incredible therapist in london who she
said would sort me out
by the end of the year and she did um
one of the most effective things she
ever said to me was i came to her and i
was telling her this person's using me
and this happened and this family did
this to me and she said well darling a
doormat's already lying down before
people wipe their feet all over it and
that was the beginning of my journey was
that sentence from that woman during
that therapy and ridding myself of all
of my mental illness based on trauma
meant that i was able to have a clear
mind and that taught me how to like
execute when it went when it meant
moving forward in activism or in my
career or as a writer or as a person
well probably it also explains why you
don't
give a [ __ ] about what people think
you've been to such dark places you've
come close to dying
jesus these things you've been through
uh of people saying some mean words
about you on the internet probably
care palestine i couldn't do this if i
gave a [ __ ] about what other people
think i'm so not interested i dislike
most people i meet and it doesn't affect
their day badly they're still you know
shagging and cooking and i don't know
unless they're fantastic television but
they don't know it doesn't have to
impact them it doesn't have to impact me
that other people don't like me i'm not
everyone's cup of tea yeah i'm rarely
anyone's cup of tea oh that's all right
well that's not true but it's that makes
perfect sense to me and uh what do you
do to help with
fear you have around not being like i
ignore i evade right you don't even read
the comments i have with instagram i
just got instagram because of this
podcast great and so
i find it a nice way to engage with
people who say nice things people say
mean things and they make me unhappy
yeah then i will ignore or i will block
or but it hasn't really happened to me i
also don't i have not said controversial
things i mean i'm not in your you're not
inflammatory no i'm quite safe i'm
threatening but i i am inflammation yes
on legs
yes
you are walking inflammation uh are
there ever times where it does get you
where it does kind of infect you or um
creep in no sometimes i feel a bit
gutted if i've actually made a mistake
and misrepresented myself so yeah i feel
a bit bad about that and that makes me
hurt at the very beginning it did used
to hurt me and i'd be like i can't
believe this journalist said this um but
now i just don't care like now i just
want to get it right and so i listen to
the criticism yeah when it's fair i take
it on and i improve and i'm grateful for
it funny i was thinking about that when
somebody had said something to you you
reposted something that it was a little
snippet of abuse and sometimes that
abuse can be fun when it's so clearly
ignorant and gross it can almost be
funny you shine a light on it in a way
that makes it
almost comedic yeah i like to try out
insults
on these people it's just like a new
word that i'd like to try out dick drip
it was a new one i don't think that's
been used before for anyone no i've
never heard that it's a very rude
man who kept on sending me like death
threats and stuff and i referred to him
as a dick drip which went down very well
and i'm glad that a lot of people have
taken that into their vocabulary now i
will oh yeah there you go
it's very it's very lucid it's very
graphic and upsetting you know
what are you offering dick drip yeah
disgusting sorry but appropriate no uh
are you ever afraid somebody who is
sending i mean death threats and stuff
like yeah i don't i don't engage too
much with the death threats because
sometimes they are followed up with
action i pick fights that i can finish
do you know what i mean like i'm not
going up against the nra because the nra
will shoot me yeah
yeah that's how that happens uh i i know
how much power i have and i'm
unfortunately one woman doing this you
know with not enough allies yet
so that was the motivation behind i way
that this is a
movement so moving against shame it
started as a conversation around just
continuously seeing pictures of
celebrities female celebrities only with
their weight written across their body
and i was i tried to find any pictures
of men with their weight written on it
and i couldn't find anything it wasn't
supposed to be a movement it was just a
post where i was like this is what i
weigh my financial independence my
activism my relationship my friendships
my eating disorder blah blah blah
and then it just went viral and it
turned into this whole thing and it
became this movement against all
different kinds of shames that affect
people with disabilities or people of
color or people who are you know who
have gender dysphoria all kinds of
different things
well again it's like you were saying how
prevalent these things are inside i mean
that probably drew a lot of people out
of the
social media woodwork because it is
so common we're all we all are infected
with it at a young age so gen z are just
like nothing we've ever seen they're so
much better than us yeah and it's really
fun to engage with them because they're
actually they actually act
on things you have hope then for this
yeah yeah they have such a big mess to
clean up we've left a shitstorm for them
do you ever think about running for
office no
no you can't do anything when you're in
office you like have so much more
freedom on the outside because you don't
have so many uh
like protocols and hurdles you know no
matter what you want to look at obama he
had so many big dreams of what he wanted
to do but there were so many people up
against him inside his uh inside of the
white house that he had to go past in
order to get anything pushed
forth and he's incredible but like
watching someone who had so many radical
wonderful ideas and seeing how hard it
was to get any of them brought into
fruition she shows me that you actually
do have more power on the outside
especially because of social media yeah
it's true the government could admit
could not have made me too happen
the people made me too happy that's true
do you think about your legacy is that
important to you where's that part of
vegan no i don't give a [ __ ] about
legacy i'll be dead i won't know yeah
that's sorry i don't think anything
happens after you die i think you just
like disappear oh really yeah i'm not
very spiritual no
really yeah
i've done all the things i wanted to do
i know but life is so fun like you got a
great boyfriend you're like yeah oh i
just don't i don't he's not allowed to
die before me that's the only rule oh
that's selfish yeah we either have to
die either i have to go first we have to
go at the same time
i can't live in this world without him
he's the best person on earth but yeah
death doesn't scare me at all because i
won't know because i'll be dead how did
you meet james uh we met because we were
both uh djs and radio djs and i
it was inside the live lounge the
esteemed live lounge at bbc radio yeah
uh we were there he
uh was waiting for his producer i was on
air and i ran out of the studio
while we were live because i had to
announce that pitbull was number one and
i just refused to say it i i was like i
can't
this is
one of the groomsmen of the apocalypse
like i'm not going to
i'm not gonna say that my country has
voted pit bull as number one i don't
care about democracy free speech okay i
just don't want pitbull
you know by the way mr bull we'd love to
have you on the show if you're listening
um
who swims in a three-piece suit come on
wait wait soon yeah uh but he uh but
yeah so i so i ran outside into the live
land like kicking and screaming and i
was just like you're not you're gonna
have to drag me back in there if you
want me to say this on it and i just
left left the uk hanging on the radio as
i ran out screaming yeah how did you
know did you get in trouble for doing
things like that i was being physically
dragged back in um
how i met and that's how i met james was
in that moment of like complete chaos
where i was behaving as badly as
possible and i think he enjoyed the
rebellion in me i bet i bet he enjoyed
that and it's
it makes sense also in the in the sense
that like you are
you're resisting talking about this
one type of musician and then you run
into somebody with like you know musical
integrity loads of intentions yeah well
yeah i mean you remember you said it
pitbull if you're listening uh he's he's
mr worldwide i appreciate that i
appreciate his hustle this is like three
a couple years ago then
five years ago so we became friends
first i moved to los angeles he followed
me out here like a tall sexy stalker and
uh
how flattering james oh he looks very
embarrassed i've heard that about him
before he's a tall
and uh musician no no the tall sexy
stalker yeah yeah yeah
uh
and we fell in love yeah that's cool
he's my best friend he's the best part
of my life that's great and so that's
also like when you when you have someone
that you admire and you love so much
love you back or like you back you don't
need anyone else to like you
that's true that's a good point just one
you just need one
yeah i'm stated by his affection
therefore i don't need the affection of
the world and whatever i was looking for
in show business is now like that void
has been filled yeah if he leaves me
that i'm really [ __ ] then you're gonna
need the people really isn't really
awkward i'll be back but you're gonna be
checking your life i'll be selling all
the influence the stuff i'll be
photoshopping i'll be doing it all
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
it's the emote yeah yeah it's the side
eye very judgy i use them in a very
judgy way oh i know what you're talking
about yeah wait um yeah that's wrong
exactly uh it's the disappointed side
eye i use quite a lot and i also use the
uh james is enthusiastically nodding his
head yeah
james is a fan of the aubergine the
eggplant oh aubergine yeah and we both
use the uh the one that bears all of it
so what's he doing he's just i can't
tell he's turning right over that's just
his natural complexion he's so he's so
used to me by the way
i've tested every depth of his like
englishness if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play
or did you play sports as a kid no oh my
god no
i know i'm so clumsy i'm sort of i think
i might actually have dyspraxia like i
can't
breathe yeah well i think it's like i
think this is so ignorant dyslexia of
the body oh you just can't seem to like
james would you say you think i'm
dyspraxia
affirmatively uh yeah i'm too clumsy
serious i hurt myself all the time i
also uh have ayla's download syndrome
which is a collagen thing that makes me
do this oh no you can see my my elbows
bend fully both ways so do my knees i'm
too clumsy for sports i could never do
sports um
i can't do action scenes there's a big
action scene in the good place where uh
all of the characters fight these demons
and they knew to not involve me in that
so they made me hide behind a pool table
during the fight scene
and i pulled my muscle in my bum from
hiding yeah from crouching for so long
that i ended up being the only one who
left with an injury at the end of the
week
i was the only one limping and i did
nothing this is a departure and and i
want to get back to this because we're
almost done um
but but this car i want to talk to you
about you i know you have to a car
accident when you were 17
what what were the circumstances that
led to that three separate times justin
i've been driven by bees into cars um so
the first one i'll go through this
quickly first one i saw a bee on the
same side as the row of the road as me
and i thought the safest way to survive
that situation would be to run into
oncoming traffic which is what i did so
i got hit by one car into another car
and damaged my back so badly i didn't
walk for a year and a half oh
my god second time i
am in season one of the good place this
is four years ago i'm running up a road
called la cienega i'm on a jog because
ted dancer told me to start jogging
because he can't believe how little
energy i have on set and he's 40 years
older than me and he's told me i should
take up exercise i'm running down this
the road i stop at a traffic stop in you
know in between two lanes of traffic and
there's a little tree on that traffic
stop i must have disturbed one of the
branches because i'm very tall and uh a
swarm of bees descended upon me because
i must have disturbed their hive oh my
god
i didn't have an epipen on me so i just
started running it's on la cienega but
they were all over me and they were
raging and i was running
ran into the road into oncoming traffic
and a car hit me i went down but it hit
me while slowing down thank god because
they'd seen this woman with like a perm
of bees running into the road so um i
went down the bees came down with me i
got up i kept running they kept chasing
me i ran for
maybe seven or eight minutes straight as
fast as i could and they were still on
me and it's like jesus christ like i'm
i'm not trying to hurt you just [ __ ] off
but they kept saying
sorry about yourself i know so i thought
i ran these people standing outside a
taco sort of club i guess it's like a
club meets a taco bar
and they were standing outside queueing
uh and smoking and i thought well those
people are smoking they don't care about
their lives so i ran at them with all of
the bees and brought the bees to all of
the smokers
they don't tell you that that's how
smoking kills well yeah it's a very
niche witness
i ducked down on the ground like a true
coward and i climbed into the juice bar
uh next door and watched everyone get
stung
and there were cigarettes flying
everywhere the other day i was
i'm gonna
i'm gonna make myself sound pretty major
right now i was speaking at the un uh
during un week yeah wow so i was
speaking at the um yeah and uh i was
running
oh no i was about to cross the road to
walk in and donald trump was in there so
[ __ ] loads of security wait a minute i'm
sorry to interrupt but you're allowed to
indulge in that but then i'd want to
indulge in it because i don't know
what and what i was speaking about
gender equality at the u.n so in front
of like world leaders and like
billionaires and
people who are able to change the world
but who don't
is that intimidating is that how does
that feel to get up in front of those
people no i think i might be on a
sociopath or something i just don't care
a very good situation told an osama bin
laden joke at the un isn't that mad
i was talking about something about
gender roles and like how women can find
absolutely anything you know that's like
one of our superpowers and uh i was like
you know i've never understood why i
don't even know if this is funny or not
but i don't know why i felt compelled to
say it because i'm a lunatic but you
want to try on your material at the u.n
yeah
i've never understood why we sent
hundreds of thousands of men to go and
find osama bin laden if we just sent my
mother
like she would have found him in a day
she would have cleaned up the caves she
would have fed everyone
yeah that's it you sent out a thing it's
not about her but about the paparazzi
yeah bothering her yeah and they do that
still i know
is it worse in england yes yeah yeah
they're really insidious really awful
yeah and so you know you have to
destabilize that with kindness and
respect i tell them i have anxiety and
they're scaring me or i tell them that
i've been raped and what they're doing
is really scaring me like when they like
crowd around me uh i just i say to them
i was like guys i'm a rape victim like
this is really intimidating and they all
just stop because they're all dads and
humans and yeah by the way i'm not
making that out but no i know this is
actually a thing that happens i know
it's really intense for me to just drop
that yeah of course yeah what a what a
great joke tactic i'm surprised you try
that joke at the u.n but the point is
that like there are ways of just like
re-engaging people very quickly into
humanity with empathy and so i use that
whenever i can like i think just being
open about your vulnerabilities helps
people feel theirs yeah
um
what kind of kid were you where were
were you interested in
i mean there's a long time i was so
[ __ ] south asian just wanted to be a
doctor oh really oh south asian yeah
your siblings uh yeah older brother he
was like a lead singer in a band like
much cooler than me and listened to
nirvana and had long hair and
yeah he was like a poet and a singer but
i was like wanted to be a doctor very
good with the money and you know
i i was very tradish
but
i
left school at 17 when i got hit by the
car and never went back so
now i'm a hollywood actress
who needs to avoid bees yes desperately
uh lonely kid bad with people uh deaf so
you stare quite a lot still stare how
deaf were you
uh completely deaf for most of my
childhood oh my god and i would go
through times where i'd have an
operation get some of my hearing back
lose my hearing have another operation
had seven major operations before the
age of 12. holy [ __ ] so you knew sign
that you would speak in sign language no
my family were more into lip reading oh
my god yeah you speak very crisply and
is that i think enunciation is like
something that i've worked very hard on
you know my accent i get hard on yeah
i've uh yeah i've i've definitely like
i'd like i wasn't
born with this accent um but i think
it's
learning how to enunciate and how to
speak proper so you had a traditional
like pakistani no traditional like for a
while i did when i lived in pakistani i
like pakistani i lived in pakistan i
developed a full pakistani accent
which my brother beat out of me because
why because it wasn't cool because at
the time it was such a racist time in
england it was like this you'll get
killed for this um
but uh you lived in pakistan
sometimes on and off it depended
wherever the pound was strongest is
where we moved as a family was that when
venice was that when bhuto was i think
she was
done by then but that must have been
amazing to see to
yeah oh my god there's actually it was
on the news once because they uh the
whole of pakistan was praying for me
because i was on air force one with her
and i was a baby i was barely like
barely a newborn and um
they were afraid her plane was going to
be shot down because obviously she's a
woman in such a tower and so she was
such a power so pakistan prayed that the
plane would make it safely because there
was a newborn you had a whole country
praying for you yeah amazing they didn't
care about her life they're like the
rest of the time she flies [ __ ]
that sweet newborn who by the way is a
little overweight yeah who's going to
turn out to be uh a bit much she'll stay
in her lane [ __ ] regret that that's
what they wish they're taking that
[ __ ] plane down jesus christ always
banging on twitter if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be hot bread with butter
hot bread hot bread with butter is that
a snack food is that all right yeah but
that's my favorite meal it's my favorite
meal in the world i spent weed yeah yes
yeah i've only found it a year ago james
gave it to me oh well done james i was
having a very stressful day
he's making the sign of a pusher yeah he
um he gave it to me once and i uh i've
never been the same since he's been much
more chilled this is my activism now on
weed can you imagine what it would have
been like years ago jesus christ when
you were only doing cocaine yes
and ketamine together yeah i'd never
taken drugs or had any alcohol until i
first smoked a little bit of weed it was
mostly cbd with a tiny little touch of
thc yeah and it was wonderful it's made
me very happy with sugar
um and so
what was the question
well there you go
i
have too much weed so i don't remember
the question yeah hot bread with hot
bread with butter i would
uh that and french fries those are the
two things that i would have as my uh
death row meal oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not into that like five that [ __ ]
five star michelin [ __ ] i hate that
food or it comes on a tiny portion and
it just
looks like a painting and it's five
hundred dollars oh see [ __ ] that food
this sounds wanky but i do like that you
partake in but i wouldn't want it for my
last meal because my last meal i would
want i would want stuff that i wasn't
crazy about well what do you want well i
mean i would want like like i would want
my favorite food is like soup dumplings
from uh there's a great place here
called excellent dumpling house or my
mother's like it does what it says on
the tin it is it really lives up to it
but if i was about to die i think i
would want food that i wasn't as i did i
didn't
i find as much pleasure in why i
wouldn't want to a reminder of the great
joys of life you know about the life
that i was about to leave i you know i
just want cabbage yeah cabbage would be
nice oh so dumb i disagree with this
notion of yours you should change it i
wouldn't want cabbage i would want
pleasure just before you you know the
pain no because then it's like oh god i
i don't want to let go of this it'd be
harder to let go of a life that that
contained all these pleasures that's so
dark yeah
well that's what we do on this show um
what's your favorite movie of all time
uh my favorite movie of all time is four
lions
four lions the rubber
no it's a it's a comedy about terrorists
you do like terrorist comedy yeah i
really love that it's always a tie
between four lions and the truman show
those are my two favorite films of all
time if you had to live somewhere else
where would it be
oh god i don't want to live anywhere
other than california justin really okay
it's where i want to grow up i want to
die here um but
i guess i love italy
because i love the way that old people
are treated there it's a good place to
grow old like you're not like
yeah in england and you know a bit the
united states you're expected after the
age of sixty just to stay in your house
yeah uh and the world is made to sound
like unsafe and unwelcoming and like
you're no longer any good to us [ __ ] off
by the window um and uh in italy you're
out you're about you're included in
everything you're drinking coffee at
midnight uh yeah you're respected you
can too you're welcomed everywhere so i
i like that about italy also the food is
amazing the people are happier there's
olive oil dripping out of their skin um
they eat carbs with reckless abandon
also they're so open with their emotions
james and i googled strange things and
we wanted to know like where the best
mental health was in the world and it
was italy oh really and it makes sense
because even the men just cry they get
everything off their chest they yell
they get they they speak openly about
their emotions i'm not saying it's a
perfect system and i know that
catholicism has reigned through that
country in a really weird
patriarchal way but
people get stuff off their [ __ ]
chests yes that's true and i like that
and it does it naturally com depression
is a
is a response to repression often uh-huh
not to sell you on japan um but there's
a movement in japan now where they
people get together and just emote it's
called like um yeah they just cry and a
lot of men uh belong to these clubs
where they just they watch sad things or
they listen to sad they listen to
james's music and they just they listen
to james
his music is not uh as sad now his
music's become happier i heard he has an
amazing woman in his life um
you've ruined him it's weird that having
like there are actual like
lines from like angry emails i've sent
him that went into his third house
it was wild like actual lines verbatim
and my ex my
watching thousands of people sing that
back by the way oh my god you're angry
you're like on the side of the stage
like that's not how i intended it
unbelievable um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive when you've never
met i want larry david to be there
because he's really great yeah he's
wonderful in person as well oh really
yeah yeah i briefly got into a scenario
where i got to know him via a group of
friends and he taught me how to drive
what he gave me driving lessons when i
first got to los angeles isn't that
bizarre i didn't know anyone i didn't
know any famous people i just randomly
ended up at a dinner with him he's so
nice and he thought it was ridiculous
that i didn't know how to drive at 30.
so he taught me how to drive in his
prius
isn't that ridiculous
so i now now know how to drive because
of larry david i'm so glad you didn't
tell me this at the beginning of this
because i would have only would have
been the whole podcast yeah yeah wait a
minute
was it not through ted danson
no through other people yeah through
other people it happens out but um so
wait wait wait wait so he took your
heart i loved you put me driving yeah
driving with mr daisy
it was just very it was very scary
because like it's because you are
laughing so much that you almost crash
all the time and like he's screaming
when you're like heading towards a wall
and it's very funny because it's this
voice that we know yeah like what are
you doing you're gonna crash uh where
did he where did you drive around santa
monica on the road spacious yeah on the
roads like and in parking lots and all
sorts of things it was just it was like
a film whilst we were very funny so he
must have really appreciated he must
have gotten we had a great time it was a
weird meeting of mines
yeah he's he's he's solid gold so i'd
want him at the table because i think
he's really funny yeah um
who else would i like i would like
someone with an epipen i'd like roxanne
gay at that dinner she's great oh yeah
she's so smart and sassy that's a
terrible word isn't it i call it roxanna
guys sassy but she's really funny and
like quick and well the way you say
yeah it's a mix between saucy and cersei
yeah sassy yeah it's just she's
brilliant i really like her i've never
met her before but i'd really really
like to i think sassy's a bad boy i
would like to because
i don't know it's a bit uh i don't know
there's something about it it feels like
it's undermining of the power that is
roxanne gay and then i want oscar wilde
there oh he's sassy oh he's the sassiest
and he loves it uh yeah i think he's so
funny and his observations have stood
the test of time i would love to know
what he thinks about social media
what he would do can you imagine how
viral he would be like all of his
[ __ ] tweets i know his his
quote still makes some of the most viral
tweets in the world i would love to know
what oscar wilde the influencer would
have been like totally and i'm like dick
drip
hey listen how we have devolved um
is gonna laugh i want us i i want oscar
wilde's take on everything that's going
on right now
desperately and sadly not that far
removed from what he dealt with he had
to contend with and uh oh so now that
like question that he faced and to know
that at least in some countries in the
world it's okay to be gay yeah how
brilliant for him to know what that
would be like yeah yeah man um oh who's
your favorite muppet uh oscar the grouch
he was english yes people don't don't
see that but that's he's an english
person yes he's quite stuffy yeah well i
also think of the statler and waldorf
who were the two judgmental older yeah
i think of them as maybe being sort of
yeah yeah
english yeah
offensive no no it's fine we're all
[ __ ] um that's okay if you could
have one superpower what would it be
have the power to make unfunny people
disappear from my periphery oh yeah you
can't be bothered
you can't be [ __ ]
people cannot be bothered with them
don't care how sincere or brilliant you
are just [ __ ] off away from me i want to
enjoy humorous people people who don't
have a sense of humor just stay away
from me i like that yeah i'd love to
have some sort of like force field that
protects me from boring people yeah well
yeah and social media really amplifies
those i know i should have said
something like world peace no i like no
no save the children but uh you're
already doing that um i need some mama's
gotta have something yeah
i just would like to be protected from
boring conversations if you could be
reincarnated as a non-human animal uh
what would it be i already feel such an
affinity with dogs
no i just i don't have time for one but
i feel like i am one yeah i i kind of
doubt i sometimes feel like i am lacking
in a frontal lobe i think people who
read my twitter could probably sense
that about me yeah but i share a lot of
similarities with dogs so i think i
naturally would lean towards a dog i'm
trying to picture you use a diagnosis
yeah yeah i mean or a sloth really
i appreciate the speed of life in which
they're allowed to just participate in
yeah they're so slow they sleep alone oh
they sleep a lot yeah i guess a sloth
um they're unproblematic faves do you
know what i mean yeah no one's mad at
everyone's mad at all almost all other
animals but the sloth is generally it's
the zendaya of animals what is that i
don't get that zendaya is the
entirely unproblematic actress style
icon who everyone loves and everything
she does is perfect and i'm a huge fan
of hers
and she's your ultimate unproblematic
fave oh and i feel like the sloth is the
equivalent of that it's just loved
universally everyone thinks it's cute
everyone thinks it's brilliant everyone
supports its slowness
this will get twisted in somewhere where
people think i'm undermining her i'm not
she's my hero i love her you love [ __ ]
but she's that she's just an entirely
she's perfect
she makes no mistakes euphoria is for
sure yeah she's just i've never seen
anything like it incredible uh beetles
uh rolling stones beatles okay so the
rollie says i've got like four good
songs okay four good songs the beatles
have a hundred thousand good songs [ __ ]
people who say that they're all they
pick the rock they're two different
entirely different bands i agree with
you so many different ways they're fun
yeah oh they were cool and they did
heroin and yeah they still saying the
beatles i'm sure yeah the beatles still
so many drugs there's so much more hair
they were all so cool um i love the
beatles they had so many more bangers
they were the [ __ ] founding fathers
of pop
so
music
have no real opinion on the matter yeah
okay um uh
what would you want your epitaph to read
how how do you want to be
buried cremated do you think about that
uh i'd like to be cremated i guess i
just i don't like the idea of coming
back to life for some reason inside of a
tomb yeah
why would i be in a tomb who do i think
i am yeah mausoleum yeah a big shrine i
don't want to come back to life in
australia i don't want a funeral
i don't like i don't want a ceremonial
sadness i just want to get cremated
and just
just leave yeah wow that's so of all the
things to admire you about that's one i
think that is at the top of my list is
that you don't have this
sense of preciousness about holding on
to life you would never
no i think life is great and i'll
indulge in it now but i'm not planning
for the future
i think if anything having so many
accidents proves to you that you can't
plan for the future so i think it's like
i've lost faith in the future so
therefore i just enjoy the now i bet
well that makes sense um
i'm one b and one car away from doom
like at all
yeah
god inhabits you must be really allergic
to bees it's my final destination i
think i'm like normal allergic to bees
but i also think my girl had a terrible
impact on me it's the deepest creepers
of bees
so you know and just to roll it back
yeah i'm sure people who made my girl
i'm very like scream made me afraid of
having a house with a garden so i can't
have a house gardener now because of
scream oh yeah i'm very
very easily influenced by film god knows
what the truman show's done to you i
mean yeah i never feel like i'm alone on
the toilet yeah
that's a whole other podcast episode
which i hope we get to do one day
because this there's been too much i
want to talk to you about and i know
we're out of time but this has been such
a thrill this has really been
fascinating i've really enjoyed it it's
so nice to meet someone that you have
looked up to for a long time and have
them not be a dick yeah so well done
thanks for not being a dick trip
yourself
so
[Laughter]
that
well that happened that happened uh was
that your british i didn't even notice
it was a proper uh she's a very proper
british voice i loved how she said
cheaper's [ __ ] creepers me too yeah
cheapest [ __ ] creepers it was hard to
receive that as an insult because it was
there were so many things going on i had
just met her first of all and
she's so tall and striking and
impressive
that to be met with and even like
playful hostility was uh
through me a little bit she was real i
mean obviously being very funny about it
all the stuff she's overcome in her life
it's funny that jeepers creepers was
something that actually affected her you
know
she kind of takes over you know you give
her a little bit well she takes the
reigns i'm new to hosting she is uh yeah
no but this is not an insult to you yeah
no it's just that you gave her a little
bit and she would kind of pick up the
ball and run with it for a while yeah
and what she was saying was very
interesting yeah but uh i noticed she
didn't require much prodding i was like
jim everett handing off to eric
dickerson everyone's gonna get that
reference she seems like she genuinely
doesn't give a [ __ ] what people think i
know she does and that is a very rare
rare and quality so i'm so fascinated by
that people like that it's such a big i
guess because it's so rare and and for
her to have gone through as much as she
went through in her life uh and to come
across anyway as being so convincingly
centered and confident and
it it it made me want doing to
investigate that um
that that ptsd treatment that she went
through the blinking thing emdr emdr um
and and there are 12 different phases of
it and it's had remarkable effects on
people uh people who've gone through
that and that is a real trauma which she
suffered as a kid oh did you go through
that but multiple traumas yeah
yeah i mean she she was a victim of rape
she was deaf she
got
into a hit by car three car accidents
that's right um
i mean she she went through it all she
you know she got in a fight with the
kardashians
um so i think i would say going through
all that probably helped her
adopt the mentality she has now which is
i don't give a [ __ ] if you don't like me
or i i can like the bar has been raised
so high in terms of her struggles and
the effects that things can have on her
uh it's almost like i wonder if it's
like when you break a bone
the bone grows back even stronger you
know so she's had all of these breaks
it's a good analogy i wonder she does
seem incredibly strong and not in like
you know some people i've met people who
present themselves that way and i feel
like i've gotten pretty good at seeing
through that if it's not authentic yeah
it also seems like it would be necessary
for her to develop that thick skin
in order to do what she does she seems
to like enjoy
pushing people's bodies
provoking and i really provocate and i
think if you cared at all what people
totally thought of you you wouldn't be
able to do that kind of you know i care
much more about what people think of me
than she does uh as such an
understatement wow it's not such an
understatement
but yeah it is an understanding i
uh to the point where i like the few
times i've
put things on social media that were in
any way
i mean i don't post things that are
controversial but i i caught a fish a
large mouth bass and uh i took a picture
with it and then threw it back people
came after me on instagram for doing
that uh animal rights people you're
torturing animals blah blah blah i felt
bad that i had caused people to be upset
i think what she deals with is a lot of
irrational hostility towards her yes and
people like angry they really mean
things about you know about her weight
oh i know body oh i've read them i'm
like really vicious things i know that
would probably bother you more than it
would bother her of course it would
bother me certainly bother me more than
would bother her yeah of course she and
that's where i think she separates
herself so that she can take all that
and again uh i think it relates to what
we were saying before she's been through
so much more than we have
she's and she's gone through it and come
out the other end so she's
she's fortified she's kind of like a
medium i think to a lot of that to the
point where she said that she was
suicidal um
in kind of a cheery way did you notice
that she was like yeah i tried to kill
myself and um
but she said it in a way that shows how
much work she's done on herself yes that
she's able to be so glib exactly yeah i
thought it was
refreshing how honest she was about the
fact that her desire to be in show
business was really about just making
money yeah you know
and she
i mean i don't i i don't feel that way
but like her priority yeah it's not
her activism that's right that's her
priority yeah and whatever helps her do
that and it's certainly in her 20s it
was just like
she talks about being miserable and she
was doing this um
this radio job the hosting job to make
and she's making a lot of money but she
was very unhappy doing it yeah i think
most you see a lot of yeah sorry but
she had a specific goal in my mind you
know she she didn't she's not doing it
for
it's like a means to an end i believe
her too and you see a lot of the
opposite you see a lot of examples of
actors um who
are like these faux activists who
they're really their priority is to you
know get acting jobs and for whatever
reason um and so she is a true you know
people will say like you'll see on
instagram it's like
actor activist
whatever you know when people describe
themselves i i think i would describe
her first as an activist well you asked
her if she would go and consider going
to politics and she was like oh my god
no yeah they don't get anything done
yeah i
like her boyfriend oh yeah i mean i
don't like her i don't know
i don't like her the way that she likes
him
but i well two things one i like him i
like his music but you don't know him as
well as she does give it some time i
know i i like him but i like them a lot
too me too you don't both have to like
them as a couple uh i do too they're uh
like just based on what i obviously i've
never seen in person together but i felt
you know i had a moment where i felt
like an old grandmother when she sees
like young love you know i was like
literally in there you know because
they're so tall but i was like looking
up at them and they were so
charming and so nice i mean it's she
said she's stated by his affection which
is so sweet yeah yeah it's like that's
all she needs because i like them so
much together and i like her so much
when she was talking about how you know
she doesn't really care what people
think except for and she she returns
this i think a few times except for jane
her boyfriend she's like obviously i
want my boyfriend to be that's a
terrible brush but she said uh i'm not
even attempting because it's such a
classy great accent i don't want to get
it wrong at all but i just did attempt
it and i got it wrong it was bad but she
said um you know except for james she
kept saying like well except for my
boyfriend obviously i care about what he
thinks i started getting really
nervous
god i hope they don't break up you know
i hope
i'm rooting for them is what i'm saying
yeah sure i was wondering what you
thought was weirder that
she's been in three car accidents
running away from bees
or that larry david taught her how to
drive i mean what's more unlikely i
think the three car accidents railing
away from beasts yeah i mean if it was
just three car accidents with separate
causes that's true uh but through all
cars
of course she's okay so we can laugh
about it she was even
i'm also imagining
someone running it's funny to see
somebody i've had a lot of funny moments
watching you christian hates bees more
than most people and it's i've i've
laughed a lot see i don't wait
you misspoke i don't hate bees more than
most people that's right you hate peace
more than most people hate bees yes
thank you i really just like you it's
true anyway okay well thank you the
letter uh okay
in the tim robbins episode we had
mentioned we told a story about i tried
to hold the hand of uh
somebody who wasn't my father who i
thought was my father it was tim
schneider's father and somebody that we
once knew kevin simmons wrote in
uh wrote a very nice letter but a very
sad letter about
tim's father jim schner
he had been in a bicycle accident five
or six years ago and he had lived the
last few years of his life as a
quadriplegic and sadly jim schneider
passed away about six weeks ago we just
wanted to
mention that that we were thinking of
the schnurr family and
the reeve foundation the christopher eve
and dana reeve foundation you can look
it up on on instagram it's it's at the
reeve foundation if you do want to
donate in
in jim's memory uh they are accepting
donations for that for spinal cord
research and so thanks to kevin and to
tim and uh everyone else who's writing
in and we have another letter now uh
we'd like to read
from amy w the subject is the muppets hi
guys i've been planning to write many
times i imagine it would be a glowing
and supportive you guys rock kind of
thing i love the show been listening
from the start love love love your
collaboration and the interplay between
you two thank you so much that's so nice
that's me i am now feeling a sense of
urgency about the muppets i would like
to suggest you consider a quick course
correction on your inclusion of the
muppets question please don't let it
fade away or be dropped for example when
bill burst started to wax poetic about
cookie monster being zen and so forth
justin hurried him along and i think
missed an opportunity for good insight
then the horror grandma jody didn't even
get the question
i was so looking forward to her response
about her favorite muppets and surely
she was alive when the late great
creative genius jim henson was starting
his career what a missed opportunity i
write with urgency to humbly suggest you
revisit the reason you included that
question in each episode from the
beginning there was wisdom in that
decision in full appreciation for your
podcast and the joy brings amy uh amy i
y you're totally right um
and and it's the reason why we did
include that question because it's a
we feel it's a real touchstone for
somebody's and a potential way of
gaining insight into somebody's uh
personality
the thing with bill is that why did i
hurry him along i don't
quite know he was going on about it and
i i guess i just felt like we had
covered it but you're right there was
probably much more opportunity to
discover why he loved cookie monster so
much and in your defense uh you did ask
grandma that's right but she didn't have
an answer
so that we just cut that part out of the
interview yeah um she just didn't have
an opinion on the muppets she was so old
when the muppets and as you said the
creative genius jim henson were
prominent and were were making all their
stuff that um i just don't think she had
processed it processed it in the way
that we did for our generation but just
don't make the mistake again i know
forward yeah thank you really uh hit the
muppets every time i think that's an
important one okay okay bert
um okay well thank okay well thanks
thank you everybody who's uh who's
writing in thanks to everybody and um
for listening
especially to jamila can you do a miss
piggy impression
hi
good no that was pretty cool
yeah i just wanted i just wanted to see
your face when you did it
i can oh thanks to jamila
uh and thank you i guess i can only do
angry miss people and thanks to all of
you for listening this has been life is
short thank you
life could be a dream
life
life is short is hosted by
justin it's produced by christian long
and megan monaco our senior producer is
michelle miesh lans
our audio engineer is sergio enriquez
thank you to sergio and our executive
producers are marcia louie and hernan
lopez for
wondering
thanks for listening
[Music]
no i always thought if i did do stand-up
it would just be it uh it would be a
buffalo bill with like a dating on a
dating website like hey my name is beryl
uh my friends call me buffalo
i like uh i like taking walks in the
park i'm about 37 years old i say active
i try to be active
um i like i have a dog named precious
she is in fact precious
um i
i love uh i love helping people out i
like you know i'm just a good time i
don't really drink anymore oh
yeah i well i have a moth collection
oh and i uh
i like to skin fat women to make a
female body suits because i body just
more fear
i feel like i was born in the wrong body
um i enjoy dancing with my penis tucked
into my legs
also ballroom dancing also with my penis
technique
mostly when i'm dancing to any style i
enjoy all sorts of styles of dancing but
uh the one common denominator is i do
have my penis touching as well
moisturizing lotion company
you know i've never seen a movie
what
yeah
are you serious you're joking
you